presque partout au Québec l'examen du
français écrit que doivent passer les
élèves de 5e secondaire connaît un taux
d'échec en hausse pas juste en haut en
forte hausse c'est ce que rapporte la
presse plus ce matin nous allons parler
tout de suite avec Isabelle plan qui est
professeur au Département de didactique
à l'UQAM bonjour
monsieur alors on parle d'une forte
proportion de jeunes qui n'atteint pas
les attentes minimales requises selon
vos propres mots dans cet article là
qu'on peut lire alors comment expliquer
cette situation
bon ben évidemment il y a plusieurs
hypothèses le qu'on pourrait poser le
même mon hypothèse je dirais de
prédilection c'est que probablement que
les élèves qui étaient déjà à risque
avant la pandémie un élève à risque
c'est donc un élève qui entre 60 et 69%
dans une matière probablement que ces
élèves-là ont souffert de la pandémie
autant ça pourrait être d'ordre
psychologique comme l'isolement mais
aussi du type d'enseignement qui était
offert et donc ces élèves-là ont accusé
un retard qui est un petit peu plus
important et là ils ont basculé en échec
donc ils sont plus uniquement à risque
mais ils sont vraiment en échec est-ce
que ces résultats signalent qu'il faut
changer le cap dans la façon d'enseigner
bon le français ou peut-être d'autres
matières c'est à dire que il faut cibler
davantage ces étudiants à risque
pour commencer faudrait valider le cette
hypothèse là parce que je dis ça parce
que on sait aussi que les taux en
diminué mais si on regarde la note
moyenne ça peut diminuer tant que ça ça
dure sa peau perdue le 15 % ce qui me
fait dire que ce sont vraiment les
élèves les plus à risque qui ont
probablement basculé parce que les taux
des chèques eux ont augmenté de façon
vraiment plus importante donc faudrait
donc la première étape ça va être de
cibler vraiment les élèves qui sont en
échec qui sont-ils sont en échec de quel
ampleur c'est par le temps d'un échec
est-ce que c'est un échec à 55% ou un
échec à 40% évidemment c'est plus
récupérable qu'on est plus près de la
note de passage mais clairement je pense
que ces résultats-là nous donnent le
signal que on peut pas juste continuer
comme si rien ne s'était passé puis
poursuivre l'enseignement régulier on
pourrait avoir des mesures d'aide
supplémentaires pour ces jeunes là mais
on pourrait aussi revoir même le
programme des années sur séquences c'est
à dire assumer que plusieurs jeunes
n'ont pas atteint les attent minimale et
faire en quelque sorte un petit peu plus
de révision de consolidation des acquis
du secondaire par exemple lorsque les
élèves arrivent au CGP bon alors quand
on regarde ces chiffres là on constate
qu'en 1900 en 2022 le taux de réussite
était quoi de
87,1% alors ça c'est l'examen c'est
l'examen du ministère là ce dont je
parle ici là alors ça veut dire quoi en
terme de correction est-ce que ça veut
dire que parce qu'on est en pandémie
l'épreuve devait être lu un peu plus
généreux un peu plus souple sachant que
dans les conditions normales les notes
seraient meilleur que comme les cases il
vient d'où
ouais c'est ça ce sont des bonnes
questions le bien sûr que c'est possible
que les c'est possible que les
enseignants est assouplis un petit peu
leurs attentes pendant la pandémie
rappelons-nous qu'il y avait pas
d'examens pendant la pandémie donc pris
parmi on avait des on a eu des résultats
on a eu l'épreuve ministérielle unique
habituelles qui valait pour 40% de la
note aujourd'hui c'est donc la première
fois qu'on a un retour de ces
épreuves-là puis ça vaut pour 20%. donc
évidemment
l'impact est un peu moins de sur le
succès général de ces éléments sur la
note moyenne qui vont avoir ce que ça
nous dit c'est peut-être que le fait
d'avoir eu un relâchement
c'est vrai que ça a pu faire en sorte
que des enseignants ont vraiment diminué
leurs attentes
moi je pense surtout que les élèves ont
peut-être un petit peu perdu
le fil avec tout ça c'est pas tant de
diminuer les attentes faut se rappeler
qu'il était à distance c'était complexe
donc c'était aussi une mesure pour aider
les enseignants puis enlever un peu de
pression donc à ce moment-là ça a été
fait ça a été fait avec des raisons on
va soutenir que le motif était quand
même tout à fait raisonnable je pense
que personne qui prévoyait que l'effet
pouvait-elle donc là peut-être que les
étudiants les élèves ont perdu je dirais
le
ont perdu la pratique si c'est le cas ça
va donner
c'est vrai répéter répéter réécrire et
écrire on finit par ça finit mon fils
par absorber tout ça en tout cas
faudrait suivre les résultats donc de
l'année prochaine des examens de juin ou
de mes pour voir un peu si une tendance
ou comment les choses se tassent
espérons d'ailleurs que c'est à cela
mais la plante merci beaucoup d'avoir
pris le temps de parler ce matin à la
prochaine
ça fait plaisir bonne journée pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]